yo yo yo what's up Samuel Leeds here we
are at the property investors crash
course and I'm backstage I'm about to
jump on stage in a moment it's like 9
a.m. or something and there is a
thousand people 1000 people on that side
reading out their lives change to learn
about property investment and strategies
step by step to become financially free
so I'm pumped I'm excited when I
finished this I got a couple of
interviews coming up with a few
celebrities which can be really cool so
I'm gonna be interviewing them and
putting them on this YouTube channel so
you'll be able to hear we've got James
Caan from Dragon's Den we've got dr.
John Demartini I'm even talking to
Patricia bright at the minute and we're
trying to work something out with her as
well so there's some really really cool
people if you want to see em see you two
different people comment below let me
know the names who you want to see
interviewed and hey if you've not been
to one of these property investors crash
courses you better come down because
they're absolutely live change in two
days people come from all over the world
to come to these programs and next we
can go to Africa Africa Uganda we're
looking at buying some land out there to
build a school for some fun fun for some
really remote village children so that's
going to be it's gonna be an interesting
week
and next two days of my life of me why
do I do this I do this because most rich
people hi it's most rich people they
hold all their secrets themselves I've
been very fortunate I've been very
successful in property and I'm just I
just don't want to hold anything back I
believe that you reap what you sow I
believe in good karma I believe that I
don't think competitively I think
collaboratively and the more people you
can help yet what they want the more
you'll get what you want the more joint
ventures you'll get so I'll look good in
the training business I love being a
property investor and I love people come
in from all over the world there's
probably going to be about 17 countries
represented in this room they will fly
in from all over the world I'll find out
in the Roman who's here
so exciting times hey thank you so much
for watching this video I really
appreciate every single one of you guys
who were subscribed whether you have met
me in person or whether you just watch
the videos I'm really grateful thank you
for your support my serious man come on
down to one of these events property
investors crash course it's where it's
at so you can just google it Google the
property investors crash course with
Samuel leaves and there'll be a link you
currently book home for free free on me
it's an amazing two-day program look at
the reviews online guys see one of my
top trainers man right
one of my top trainers we've got some
serious sister said he's multi
multi-millionaire property investor we
get people coming in you know to help
out as well with some of the training
and just means everyone gets added value
added perspectives which is fantastic so
guys have a wonderful weekend whatever
you're doing and I'm going to jump on
stage now so I'll see you guys later
thank you so much
let's just have a quick peek let's have
a quick peep
okay hold us ready